today we're looking at this very short
easy-to-read existentialist novel by
Albarn coming with a stranger like it
said at the beginning easy to read both
in English and in French in part because
of the the word choices the way in which
is written and in part I think it has to
do with the very notion that Mer solo is
himself the absurd man there's not an
awful lot of backtracking that you have
to do in order to make sense of things
characters kind of flit in flip-out you
get a sense of impression of lot
surfaces but not an awful lot of depth
that you have to explore this this was a
very important book for Camus for many
people who were studying existentialist
literature and some people took it along
with jean-paul Sartre nausea as being in
some ways the prototypical
existentialist novel the prototypical
piece of literature showing us what an
existentialist life would be like I
don't think that's actually the best
read that one can have on it in part
because come and wrote you know other
works as well including the plate which
we're going to look at later on but does
fit fairly well with his other main
earlier work the mythos if assess so
we're going to get this one and we'll
spend about an hour on it in this
lecture one of the things you can start
with to begin with if you've read the
myth the synthesis which is about the
the absurd and the type of way of life
we ought to embrace in the face of
absurdity you can ask yourself is the
main character of this novel the absurd
man it's coming putting forth here a
hero for the existentialist a model that
we want to
follow what are something else going on
is this a good fit with the mythos
synthesis or are these these projects
that are connected but going off in
different directions I think if you look
at some of the characters particularly
at this main character or so and you
look at what is going on within the work
the answer is actually a highly
qualified yes this represents one way of
looking at the absurd man but by no
means the only way and not even the best
way but we'll get to that a little bit
later when you're looking at a novel one
of the things that you want to do is not
only try to call out the philosophical
meet you know the kernel of it but to
look at how things are depicted
particularly with Como if you remember
in mythos if assists in discussing
absurd creation Camus says that
philosophy and literature and art have
to sort of fuse together that it's not--
we're no longer at the time of the
abstract philosophical system we're now
at the time where philosophy life and
literature kind of flow in together as
ways of taking a stand ways of
experimenting and exploring the type of
charting of experience and reflection
that a philosopher does is more akin to
out of the mind of the novelist Ruth or
perhaps the poet or the short story
writer maybe even the sculptor or the
artists painter than what was going out
of the mind of a previous time
philosopher you know when there are
supposed to be systems and everything
should be reduced to some sort of set of
propositions so you know it is tempting
to try to read more soul as everyman but
part of the point that coming was making
in the mythos if is's is there is no
everyman
the absurd takes that possibility of
weakness so what is going on in this
well we see some portions of the life of
the main character it's told through his
eyes this guide nor so who is not a
particularly good guy not a particularly
bad guy as a matter of fact he's
somebody who in many ways lacks
convictions is kind of floating on the
surface of life what else do we say
about it
well we're seeing the world and we're
seeing other people through his eyes and
eventually we get to see his reflections
on himself and his own life as well but
we don't get any really sustained ones
until the very end in the central act
that is the pivot it's actually you know
the matically the way that the very book
is set up you have Part one and Part two
the central act that actually binds them
together is this this you know we're
gonna use this word absurd a lot but in
some ways you can say you're rational
rather the
merely absurd or in the characters own
eyes not entirely explicable killing of
another human being an arab with with
whom he has some sort of tangential
connection because the arab is a friend
of another guy who is at odds with our
souls friend sort of friend
raymond and they're kind of fighting by
proxy you might say and that's sort of a
good a good way of understanding the
whole novel a lot of things they're
having happening by proxy so let's talk
about this guy more so at first what can
we say about from the very start well he
works in an office we know that early on
because he has to ask off why because
his mother has died his mother used to
live with him but she's been sent to an
old folks home some distance away he's
living in north africa and what about
the rest of his family he has no other
family so he's a fairly isolated type
his father died a long time ago we don't
know much about him from the novel we
don't hear about any other family so
that's not really central to him so what
are this guy's attachments what what you
know what else is he surrounding himself
well he's got his office mates and added
a little bit of talk about that there's
the boss of his office but the people
who really end up mattering more are
these kind of accidental friendships
that occur and one romantic partner
buried so we're going to talk about each
of those in turn but first we want to
ask about or at least posed the question
this guy here so what is his character
like what is the kind of life that he
has on some level maybe not so much
consciously or deliberately but just by
falling into it or allowing it to take
hold of him what is the life that he has
chosen what are the values that he
actually holds dear espouses cherishes
these are hard to answer in part because
again he is the absurd man he doesn't
really seem to have an awful lot of
values we'll see precisely how this
plays itself out in a couple minutes so
we've got this gamer soul now we've got
him in place who else is playing an
important role in the story well um his
mother I suppose who's dead at the
actual start of Indy and he never
actually names her he tells us a few
things about her for example when she
was in home with me mum I use to spend
her time following me with her eyes not
saying a thing for the first few days
she was at the home she cried a lot but
that was because she wasn't used to it a
few months later and she would have
cried she'd been taken out she was used
to it it was partly why I didn't go
there much this year he says she
develops friendships at the home she's
you know she's connected with her son
but not in any deep way that makes him
you know Express missing her or her in
fact missing him either there's a little
bit of reflection at the very end where
he says for the first time in a long
time I thought about my mom I felt as if
I understand why at the end of her life
she had taken a fiance why she had
played at beginning again even there in
that home where lives were fading out
everything was a kind of wistful respite
so close to death my mom must have felt
free then and ready to live it all again
nobody nobody had the right to cry over
her so she's a woman at the very end of
her life in this novel and there's
there's no reflection on the meaning of
her life what happened before the whole
what she was like as a young woman it's
she's just treated as sort of this this
person at the very end and the novel
begins with with her death at her
funeral
who else another woman who's very
important to the novel Marie what can we
say about her from the very start
well he he introduces her in shopping to
and he says in the water I ran into
Maria Cardona a former typist in her
office
who might had a thing for four at four
at the time she did - I think but she
left soon afterwards and we didn't have
the time
so he goes swimming with her and he
talks about you know she turned towards
me her hair was in her eyes and she was
laughing
I wasted myself up next to her it was
nice and sort of joking around and left
my head fall back and rest on her
stomach she didn't say anything so I
left it there and they you know they
become entangled romantically and
sexually and they just sort of fall into
it they both they they're both attracted
to each other in the past how did he
meet her original ages through the
office so it's one of these you know
chance encounters that then plays itself
out again but she will become a very
important character through this another
character who is quite emblematic though
maybe you're not important is Sol Amato
and he described him this way he's
talking about him in terms of his dog he
was with his dog the two of them have
been inseparable for eight years
the spaniel is a skin disease mange I
think which makes all of its hair fall
out and leaves them covered with brown
sores and scabs after living together
for so long the two of them alone in one
tiny room they've ended up looking like
each other
old solemn Otto has ribs on his face and
wispy yellow hair as for the dog he's
sort of taken on his master's stooped
look muzzle down next straining they
look as if they belong to the same
species so
the same you know old phenomenon that
people have noted with you know old
couples looking like each other is
happening with this guy in his do I
sounds almost idyllic and then he
switches it by saying yet they hate each
other
twice a day at 11 and six the old man
takes a dog out for a walk they haven't
changed their route in eight years
you can see them in the route of the all
the dog pulling the man along until old
solid model stumbles then he beats the
dog and swears at it the doing towers
and trails behind then it's the old man
who pulls the dog once the dog is
forgotten starts dragging the master
along again and again gets beaten and
swore net so there they're both you know
engaged in this dynamic where they're
essentially pushing each other's bottoms
and of course you know the old man has
more agency he is stronger he's the one
who gets to beat the dog the dog is just
a dummy animal and he says this has been
going on for eight years Celeste was
always saying it's pitiful but really
who's to say this is this typical nurse
so observation who's to say I said good
evening but the old man just went on
cursing so I asked him what the dog had
done he didn't answer all he said was
filthy stinking bastard
then without turning around he asked he
answered to the kind of suppressed rage
he's always there so you have these two
almost joined at the hip one human one
not human beings the old man and his dog
and they're emblematic of something you
can see echoes of the you know
discussions and the myth of synthesis in
this they're condemned to be with each
other and then later on when the dog
disappear as the old man it doesn't know
what to do
who else is important centrally
important this guy raymond and he talks
about it first as my other neighbor
Raymond is a guy a fairly bad character
in repute he says the word around the
neighborhood is that
lives off women but when you ask him
what he does he's a whole warehouse
guard
generally speaking he's not very popular
but he often speaks to me and sometimes
stops by my place for a minute because I
listen to him I find what he has to say
interesting besides I don't have any
reason not to talk to him his name is
Raymond sand test he's a little on the
short side with broad shoulders and a
nose like a boxer he always dresses very
sharp and once he said to me talking
about Sallah motto if that that isn't
pitiful he asked me didn't I think it
was disgusting and I said no and so
Raymond you know is reacting to solemn
Otto you notice mere soul says well I
don't really care it's not really my
business I'm not making a judgment about
it
they become connected and he describes
himself as a guy who has a short fuse
and he gets himself embroiled in all
these different things he has underworld
connections so he's kind of a if not a
criminal himself sort of on the edge of
that there's a few other important
characters that of great importance but
but they'll turn up later on
there's this guy Perez who was you know
engaged to merciless mother towards the
end of ism and it his in her life
this guy's the last who runs a
restaurant there's a muscle to whose
place Marie and mer so and Raymond are
all invited on the day where he does
kill the Arab there's the Arab
themselves who are just picked it as
these these figures who come in come out
there's this girl involved as well with
Raymond but none of them get described
in any great
there's a lawyer for mayor so who shows
up a little bit later on and he is worth
talking about a little bit he describes
it as short and chubby quite young his
hair carefully slicked back despite the
heat he had on a dark suit of wing
collar and an odd-looking tied with
broad black and white stripes says that
his case is a tricky one but he had no
doubt something that they win if our
sole trusted him and then he you know
goes through and explains some things
and he wants to get mayor so - to be a
good client and to show remorse and to
to say that he did mourn his mother and
all those sorts of things but he's not
able to get cooperation out of her soul
turns out to be a good histrionic lawyer
you know he's able to object at the
right point and come up with decent
arguments there is a prosecutor who is
also described and plays an important
role because you he's the one who
actually gets marisol convicted and
sentenced to to death he talks about him
as a tall thin man dressed in red and
wearing a pin snake who was carefully
folding his robe as he sat down the
prosecutor is pretty sharp given to you
know making arguments that quit mere so
in the worst possible light
then finally there's Chaplin towards the
end of the novel and the chaplain has
been trying to you know towards ian is
trying to pester him he wants him to
feel remorse to seek forgiveness to
accept God into his life and the
chaplain in
is not so much obsessed but this is his
job is his set of values Marysol talks
about him being in some ways gentle but
also can obtain kind of bothers them
and eventually he'll blow up it so these
are the main characters that we've got
so far what's the action what's going on
when we talk about plot in a novel
particularly a philosophical novel there
are certain things that we want to pay
close attention to so we want to know
first of all what happens right at any
time that you have a plot it's a matter
of this thing happened then that thing
happened and they were connected
together in some way otherwise it's just
you know sound and fury signifying
nothing right it's just a bunch of
incidents all thrown together and when
you first read through this you might
actually get the sense that Camus is
depicting just a bunch of juxtaposed
events that have no intrinsic connection
with each other that's not really the
case though the the type of life that
Marceau is leading doesn't necessitate
what happens on the beach with the Arab
than the shooting but it leads him into
it and that event gets him into the
meshes of the French justice system and
once you're in there you know the wheels
turn and things happen the way that they
do with a certain kind of regularity so
I don't think that this book is
depicting just a kind of meaningless
life where you know first this happens
and that this happens and this happens
and none of them have any connection to
each other
I think it's depicting a state like that
at the beginning gradually flowing into
something that you could think of like a
mechanism so there's what what happened
and then we can also ask what is being
experienced watching something happen is
something a little bit different than
just you know being a spectator
there's experiencing something when you
have some sort of personal investment
and again I think you could look at this
novel as having a progression of
somebody who gradually comes to realize
his own investment in his own life and
the people around him and the world and
it doesn't make sense him it is still
absurd in the very end but there is some
sort of element of personal experience
rather than just being a spectator again
with a philosophical novel you can ask
two other very important questions so
you've asked what happened or what was
done what was experienced what was
reflected up what do the characters or
at least the main character what do they
think about what do they meditate upon
what do they obsess about what do they
come to realise and that leads us to the
last important question what was learned
are there any lessons here and that's
work it's really interesting I mean if
it's supposed to be an absurdist
atheistic existentialist text then you
might say well nothing should be learned
right or the only things that should be
learned is that life is absurd and
without meaning and try not to shoot any
any Arabs or anybody else so you don't
get in trouble but I think there is
something more learned and conveyed in
this novel at certain points
it's it's kind of fragmentary there's
not a coherent picture as there might be
in some other philosophical works of
literature but there are some things
being learned along the way so let's run
through the the plot now what actually
does occur in this is nothing so we
begin in chapter 1 in part 1 with his
mother's vigil and in funeral and
there's a lot of great description used
there to talk about the what the night
is like with the day is like all these
incidents that are going on and you get
the sense of you know fairly typical
scene you know there's this sense when
we're dealing with death that everybody
should be very attached to the deceased
that they should spend a lot of time
remembering them that they should be
heartbroken
shaken up inside regretting all the
things that they didn't do or didn't say
and you know just as much in the 1930s
and 1940s as today that's often not the
case
I mean I'm not saying that that ought to
be the case that sometimes we we don't
feel grief in the way that people expect
us to and sometimes we don't
feel much grief at all when somebody
dies but that is a part of life and you
know come in when he was talking about
in the mythos if assess how they absurd
you know pops out at us at a different
different moments how we can you know
realize our existence is absurd he
talked about death and I think that just
as much you know you've got this great
description in here of this vigil event
that he's supposed to participate in and
it really is absurd because his mother
wasn't religious he's not religious and
yet this is a tradition that's being
carried on and you've got like an entire
almost Greek chorus of older people from
the home who are her friends someone who
presumably are religious and someone who
presumably are just doing it because
it's tradition yeah there's a kind of
pageantry to it but you're you're
wondering why the hell are you doing
this what does anybody getting as you
can ask these kind of utilitarian
questions about it and everybody can
have a response you know some people can
say well look it's tradition tradition
matters to me well that makes some sense
but it may not make sense to this person
over here the person over here may say
look I don't get why we're doing this at
all I think I'd rather have brunch and
chat about you know what the person's
life was like and this is this is a
common problem not just for French
people or for you know 21st century
Americans you see debates about this in
ancient China having to do with the
rituals that were involved in mourning
somebody you see discussions of this
everywhere so this is an important
beginning and you have this character
Missal who's quite unattached
to his his mother and her predicament so
the funeral goes on and then in the next
chapter it's Sunday and he's back home
and he is out and fighting stuff to do
and the first thing that he finds to do
is to meet up with at the beach with
this woman Marie and he tells her you
know she he catches up with her you know
they're swimming he asked that she wants
to go to the movies that evening she
says yeah okay let's go on a date and
they get dressed and she sees him
wearing a black tie and she says what
are you in the morning and he says yeah
mother died so she wanted to know how
long ago and he said yesterday and she
gave kind of a little started it's a
little weird too one of one of the
movies but you know again if you know
what people are like when they are
having you know people close to them die
their responses are a little all over
the map there's no one single response
I remember that myself but you know come
from a big family you have a lot of
people die and sometimes you know you
get announced you had no way of going
there that that's so-and-so had died and
you say well I'm not going to be able to
make it to there
and sometimes you'd feel bad saying
prayer for them you know remember them
and sometimes you were in the middle of
something and sometimes you just didn't
feel like doing it at that time now
isn't that the time for me to sort of
reflect on on my own stuff at great
length but I'll say that you know my
father died when I was a child and I
remember still quite vividly being in
the back of a car and my aunt telling me
after a long illness that he wasn't able
to shake and even at the Mayo Clinic
they weren't able to deal with
we knew the writing was on the wall and
I felt like there was something expected
of me and all I felt was sort of a sense
of happiness and when my mother died it
was somewhat different I was thrown into
all these different things that had to
be taken care of
and preparations and I never really
broke down and cried even though I loved
her during during that time and you feel
these these senses of almost like
distancing so it's not shock necessarily
it's it's um maybe there's something
wrong with those of us who don't
immediately grieve like like more so but
you get a sense that there's no
understanding that this would actually
be the wrong thing except on the part of
other people like looking at him and
saying oh he's not a loving son he's
he's not caring he's a bad person but if
a person doesn't actually feel it should
they cultivate the outward appearance of
it
Mayr so doesn't even seem to consider
that that question it will come up later
on when they're debating about these
things
trial chapter 3 is back to work in
Chapter three we mean solemn otto and
his dog and we meet raymond and we come
in to Raymond's predicament Raymond has
a girlfriend who he believes he's
actually sort of keeping her and is
paying for her place and he believes
that she's cheating on him and he got
into a fight with her brother the other
the other day on the streetcar they're
Arabs and Moors she says sort of using
these interchangeably so there's some
bad blood going on and he brings in Mara
so he tells him the story he wants to
get his take on it and he brings Mir so
into his problem and makes him part of
his response and we're so doesn't resist
more so goes along with it look at that
in a moment
chapter four Raymond a actually has a
trick plate he come he has a girl to
come to his place and then he beats her
and somebody calls the cops the cops get
involved and her so doesn't want to get
involved himself but then he ends up
sort of testifying on Raymond's behalf
another important thing happens all
Amano loses his going and there's
there's a question of what is it what
he's going to do and what you see in
both of these cases is Maher so being
there with other people but not not
fully being engaged talking with them
even in some ways almost commiserating
with them that's but not fully I'm going
to read you this passage from a distance
I noticed old saw a model standing on
the doorstep you look flustered when we
got closer I saw he didn't Emma's dog he
was looking all over the place turning
around peering into the darkness
muttering incoherently
then he started searching the street
again with his little red eyes when
Raymond asked him what was wrong he
didn't answer right away I barely heard
him mumble stinking bastard and then I
went fidgeting around I asked him where
his dog was he snapped at me and said he
was gone
then all of a sudden the words came
pouring out any tells I don't know
what's what's going on and the old man
gets very worried that somebody will
take the dog away from him and that
nobody will take him in and that they'll
take him to the pound and they said this
is Marisol so I told him he should go to
the pound and they'd give the dog back
to him after he paid a fee he asked if
it was a big fee I didn't know then he
got mad pay money for that bastard ha he
can damn well die and he started cursing
the dog a little bit later the old man
comes up to nurses apartment and he says
they're not going to take him away from
me are they this year - ole they'll give
him back to me otherwise what's going to
happen to me there's this old man has
the sense that this dog is too much part
of him and he doesn't know what will
happen to him afterwards
I told him that the pound kept dogs for
three days so that their owners could
come and claim them that after that they
did with them as they saw fit he looked
at me in silence then he said good night
he shut his door and I heard him pacing
back and forth his bed creaked and from
the peculiar little noise coming through
the partition I realized he was crying
for some reason I thought of my mom but
I had to get up early the next morning I
wasn't hungry and it went to bed without
an a dinner so what you see in this is
represented narrative li mur so doesn't
feel bad for the old man he notices that
he's crying it reminds him for some
reason that he can't quite place of his
own
perhaps buried grief for his mother and
then he just resorts back to the sort of
routine now I'm going to go to bed I'm
not hungry so that'll be in Chapter five
moving out a little bit more we have
this fatal invitation by Ravens friend
Mossad through Raymond to go out to the
beach house yeah there's an important
path which Marie asks him about are they
going to get married
chapter six is leading on to this
central event they go to the beach they
have a very nice time except the Arabs
follow them along and eventually there's
a confrontation between an Arab and
Raymond Raymond has brought along a
pistol too by the way he's going to you
know use deadly force and the Arabs have
knives so things are coming to a head
they go back to the beach house the
herbs are still out on the beach in a
different spot and mer so yes Raymond
for his pistol just you know keep it
away from him so he's not going to get
himself in trouble puts it in his pocket
he goes out takes a walk and he runs
one of the Arabs and he knows that he
could get away he could back out of this
but he doesn't and then something
happens oh look at that
after that the rest of the novel part 2
is concerned with now he's part of the
Justice ISM what's going to happen -
Martha - Marysol so chapter one he's
arrested he meets his attorney chapter 2
is about prison life and he sees Murray
through one of those you know glass
things chapter three the trial begins
the judge begins preparing the case
examining him you're slightly different
justice system judges are much more
hands-on they are here in America the
witnesses get called and each one of the
witnesses is asked to you know say
something that the prosecutors eyes is
used to you know tear down Marcel's
character the defense attorney is using
it in some ways to build them up and in
other ways to just sort of you know try
to hold off the attack that's taking
place chapter four the two different
attorneys give their some nations while
Marysol was sitting there listening and
waiting they're two different versions
of Marcel's life essentially and then
he's found guilty the very last chapter
is concerned with the time in which he's
awaiting his appeal in execution and it
culminates in a moment of conflict with
the chaplain who's been trying to see
him over and over and over again so
that's that's the basic plot now let's
look at some things a little bit more
closely a little bit more
carefully so first this question is
mayor saw the absurd man there's a few
things we need to keep in mind from a
Keynesian perspective so if you're
coming riding the mythos if assist and
then writing the stranger there is no
one single absurd man who stands for
everybody's the experience of absurdity
that can't work there can't be this
absurd existence this absurd existence
this absurd existence and they can have
some things in common but there's no one
single thing so the guy in here is not
every existentialist every atheistic
existentialists every atheistic
existential is talking about the absurd
it's not that cut-and-dried
the other thing that we want to keep in
mind is for Camus we're talking about
the absurd
one of the things that we have to
remember recent very well put it down
here is the act the absurd has three
parts it's not just one single thing it
has to do with the relation between the
human being the world and the connection
between the two of them what Camus tells
us in mythos if Issus is that the absurd
on one pole of it is the human being who
is rational who expects things to be
rational to fit our conceptions for the
world to be a familiar place who is also
motivated by a desire for a nostalgia
for rationality for sensibility or for
things working out the way that they
want to at the same time what what is
the world like the world is irrational
even the world of other human beings
composed of those other selves who are
themselves wanting things to make sense
to be rational insofar as their the
world and not oneself are irrational the
controvert wants desires you see that
really clearly in this where over and
over again May or so is being offered a
chance to sort of fit into somebody
else's scheme to fit into somebody
else's understanding of how things ought
to work you know rejecting that he's
saying hey I don't want that that's not
me that's part of absurdity as well the
disconnect or the disjunction or the
lack of equivalence however you want to
put it the bad relation between putting
a big mess here right between the human
being and the world that is also part of
the absurd so you have three poles human
being world the disjunction or discord
between them all of those together
comprise the absurd so take any one of
them out of the picture and you no
longer have absurdity you have to have a
subject you have to
you have to have the failure for them to
line up properly together so is this
happening in more Souls case I think
yeah you can say this is happening in
Marshall's case and it's something that
isn't happening so much at first except
you know he goes off to the funeral and
he's wondering how am I doing here
you know why are we why are we traipsing
along in the Sun you know it's beating
down on us and we're sweating and you
know they're easy asking on you want to
open the coffin and look at your mom's
why do I want to do that
he's already experiencing an absurd
world to self relation another thing
that we can ask if we want to say that
that that verso is the absurd man does
he fit come his ethics Camus talks about
the need to live without appeal to you
know withstand thus absurd existence
even while other people are sort of like
demanding that you you do otherwise I
think in this respect a actually mayor
so does fit the type pretty well he's
living without hope although you know at
the very end there's there's he gets rid
of the hope that he has vanishes so
maybe you can say that he's not fully
the absurd man until the very end but he
does fit cow Moos ethics fair fairly
well the other thing though is he lives
an isolated life in many respects in the
middle of other people and here I'm a
little bit troubled because in some of
cow Moos
later works especially the plague and in
his notebooks you see that others matter
to him then he is kept you know
well you know one only lives one's own
life as a self but that doesn't mean
that one has to be so isolated as mere
so ends there's no intrinsic reason for
an atheistic existentialists
that says that you can't do that but I'm
not sure that that's the model I'm not
sure that that's for somebody like
having the best now you know there are
some problems in being able to like
arrange things in a hierarchy and camu
tends to flatten things out instead but
I think you can say I mean this this guy
his life is not as good as some of the
characters in some of the company's
other other works so let's think a
little bit more about his character but
he's not negative in the sense of like
opposing resisting even undermining but
he's certainly not positive
he barely commits himself deliberately
to anything when he's offered lots of
opportunities to sort of join in and
commit himself when there's
opportunities for him to have a change
of heart to alter his direction he
doesn't take it he just sort of floats
along and this happens in occasion after
occasion after occasion sometimes when
people are offering these to him you
might say well that would be a loss of
his freedom or a loss of his dignity but
it's not quite so easy to say that in
other cases like you know re wanting to
get married for being offered the chance
to participate in some sort of
remembrance and warning of his mother or
you know even to some extent the
engagements with the attorney and the
prosecutor to kind of make sense out of
these things
personal way those aren't necessarily
bad things that would you know impinge
upon his human freedom or his dignity or
his his life is a kind of a troubling
novel you know I have a very different
take on this
reading it as a 40 year old man that I
did reading it as a 15 year old teenager
and I think other people might have the
same so he's not really positive is not
really negative you can look at his
relations with with other people and
what's going on so I just want to focus
on four in particular what is Raymond
himself now Raymond is he's depicting
himself is not a particularly bad guy
but he is a bad guy and so Raymond says
to me or so
they are so describing it so you see I
wasn't the one who started it he was
asking for it it was true and I agreed
then he told me that as a matter of fact
he wanted to ask my advice about the
whole business because I was a man I
knew about things I could help him out
and then we'd be pals that's a key thing
with rain being pals that's what draws
in Marysol to this this whole business I
didn't say anything
notice merciless response I didn't say
anything and he asked me again if I
wanted to be pals now notice this
response I said it was fine with me he
seemed pleased so he doesn't take a
position he says yeah ok we can be pals
he's not committing himself yeah and
there seems like no thought going into
it whatsoever a little bit later he he's
explained the whole situation to him and
he he wanted to know what I thought of
the whole thing I said I didn't think
anything but that it was interesting so
he won't give a judgment he says yeah
that's interesting but I'm not going to
actually say one one thing or another he
asked if I thought she was cheating on
him and it seemed to me that she was if
I thought she should be punished and
what I would do it is place and I said
you can't ever be sure but I understood
his wanting to punish her so I can sort
of sympathetic through this this
essentially dirtbag guy not sitting down
any limits not ever saying no I'm not
going to do that I will I will go in
that direction just having it all sort
of weak preferences for this or for that
that's that's the way more so is the
irony is how does it end I got up
Raymond gave me a very firm handshake
and sudden men always understand each
other
he says now you're a pal more so and
again and said it again that it struck
me he repeated his remark and I said yes
I didn't mind being his pal and he
seemed set on it this is after he writes
a letter setting up this this woman to
come to Raymond's place to you know get
beaten up to have him take revenge on
her he doesn't think about it he doesn't
seem to you know place any moral qualms
in play about this he doesn't express
any real strong values desires all he
has are these sort of you know floating
preferences let's look at Marie when he
when he's talking with Marie and she
says oh here we go that evening Marie
came by to see me and he asked if I
wanted to marry her I said it didn't
make any difference to me and that we
could if she wanted to then she wanted
to know if I loved her I answered the
same way I had the last time that it
didn't mean anything that I probably
didn't love her this is you know this is
pretty tough stuff this was somebody
about whom you might say what's going on
with this guy
he's either not understanding the
questions that are being put to him or
he genuinely doesn't care about them or
he's you know in some way maybe pushing
her away or he sees everything as
meaningless as absurd as kind of
flattened out as having the same value I
think that that's the latter love
doesn't have any real value
I mean he's willing to have sex with her
because he knows that he enjoys that and
she you know presumably she does too but
he's not really sure about anything like
love she says why marry me that I
explained to her it didn't really matter
if she wanted to we could get married so
again you see that same sort of floating
along well if you want to do the
yeah okay that's fine by me I don't
really care one way or the other and I'm
willing to oblige you sort of mentality
and then he said besides she was what I
was doing the asking and all I was
saying was yes then she pointed out
marriage was a serious thing I said no
she stopped talking for a minute and
looked at me without saying anything
then she spoke she just wanted to know
if I would have accepted the same
proposal from another woman with whom I
was involved the same way I said sure
then she said she wondered if she loved
me there was no way I could know about
that so I get to see the isolation of
this this character he's he's just not
connected with this woman who's
proposing that they get married and he's
saying yeah you know if somebody else
came along and said the same sort of
thing you know if I was sleeping with
her that I would get married that's fine
she was insistent enough about it you
know that's you can't even really talk
about his character so much it's just
lack of character if we look at well I'm
going to skip ahead actually we'll come
back to the Chaplin and absurd life
let's look now the the act of firing the
pistol which is pivotal to this whole
story so how does the Arab die he's on
the beach he's got Raymond's gun the
Arab is on the beach and he has a knife
and he says it occurred to me all I had
to do is turn around and that would be
the end of it but the whole beach
throbbing in the Sun was pressing on
so the world is in some ways you know
impeding him pushing him on I took a few
steps toward steps toward the spring the
Arab didn't move besides he was still
pretty far away maybe it was the shadows
on his face but it looked like he was
laughing the Sun was starting to burn my
cheeks that I could feel strop some
sweat gathering in my eyebrows he goes
out a little bit more about that it was
this burning which I couldn't stand
anymore that made me move forward I knew
that it was stupid that I wouldn't get
the Sun off me by stepping forward so
he's trying to you know he's reacting
human being has its instincts has its
reason it's reacting to this world which
is you know controverting its desires
and he's just trying to get out of this
irritation I took a step one step
forward and at this time without getting
up the earth the Arab drew his knife and
held it up to me in the Sun the lights
shot off the steel and it was like a
lawn flashing blade cutting at my
forehead at the same instant the sweat
and my eyebrows dripped down over my
eyelids all at once and covered them
with a warm thick film my eyes were
blinded me behind the curtain of Tears
and salt so he you know says that's when
everything began to real my whole being
tensed up and I squeezed my hand around
the revolver the trigger gave I felt the
smooth underside of the butt and there
in that noise sharp and deafening at the
same time is where it all started
he says I knew that I had chanted the
harmony of the day the exceptional
silence of a beach where I'd been happy
then I fired four more times that the
motion was body where the bullets lodged
without leaving a trace and it was like
knocking four times on the door of
unhappiness that's the question that
everybody wants to know is shot the guy
once why did you shoot him four more
times and mersa was not able to give a
status back
answer when the magistrate asks him in
chapter chapter 1 of the second part the
magistrate asked if I'd fired all five
shots at once I thought for a minute
that explained that at first I'd fired a
single shot and then a few seconds later
the other four then he said why did you
pause between the first and second shot
once again I could see the red see and
feel the burning of the Sun in my
forehead but this time I didn't the
answer why didn't he answer later the
mattress is why why did you shoot at a
body that was on the ground once again I
didn't know how to answer to try to make
sense of this absurd disconnect while
being present at the same time which is
what's going on in the irritation
between the human being and the world
and especially with dealing with another
human being it's very difficult to put
into words that another person can say
yes that makes sense i absolve you I
relieve you of responsibility you did
the right thing there so is unable to do
that with this this experience that he
has he didn't actually do the right
thing and he took somebody's life he
could have backed away he certainly
didn't have to shoot him five times but
he's unable to even make it fully
explicable to the magistrate in part
because he's not able to make it
explicable to himself
the prosecutor picks up on this in the
trial and
asks him why he shot six times again
he's unable to to give an account of it
he says you know did you go back to the
spring intending to kill the Arab no
well then why was I armed and why did I
return to precisely that spot I said it
just happened that way
that's all mere silicon science it just
happened that way there's no meaning to
it it is absurd
later on the prosecutor will make a lot
of hay out of the fact that there so
never expresses remorse he says I heard
him say has he so much as expressed any
remorse never gentlemen at this point he
turned in my direction not once during
during the preliminary hearings of this
man show emotion over his heinous
offense and Marisol says of course I
couldn't help admitting that he was
right I didn't feel much more sure what
I'd done but I was surprised by how
relentless he won I would have liked to
have tried explaining to him cordially
almost affectionately that I've never
been able to feel remorse for anything
my mind was always on what was coming
next today or tomorrow but naturally
given the position I'd been put in I
couldn't talk to anyone that way I
didn't have the right to show any
feeling or goodwill he's recognizing
things about himself you know it's
interesting something that you could ask
is a live question about this more
Persol character is could the world be
absurd for him could he be ups the
absurd man in that world without it
necessarily being so for everybody else
if we go a little bit further and I am
actually going to skip over is his
prison experiences those are worth
reading because there's a growing
awareness not necessarily like moral
their personal growth but at least a
growing awareness of the condition that
he's now in there's a capping when he
has now been condemned and he is hoping
to have an appeal and the prison
chaplain is going to him trying to
convert you not to waste his prayers on
me I grabbed him by the collar of his
cassock I was pouring out on him
everything that was in my heart cries of
anger and cries of joy he seemed so
certain about everything did he and he
had none of the certainties was worth
one year of a woman's head he wasn't
even sure he was alive because we were
living like a dead man but it says but I
was sure about me about everything sure
that he could ever be sure of my life
insurer of the death I had waiting for
me yes that was all I had but at least I
had as much of a hold on it as it had on
me I had been right I was still right I
was always right I had lived my life one
way and I could just as well have lived
in another that's again absurdity
there's no one single right way to do
things no right way to live for Camus I
had done this and I hadn't done that
that I hadn't done this thing but I had
done another and so it was as if I had
waited all this time for this moment so
he's having an epiphany now but it's not
an epiphany where like you know the
heavens open up and now everything makes
sense it's going to be an epiphany of
things not making sense
nothing nothing mattered and I knew why
so did he
throughout the whole absurd life I lived
a dark wind had been rising toward me
from somewhere deep in my future across
years that were still to come and as it
passed this wind leveled whatever was
offered to me at the time and years no
more real than the ones I was living
what did other people's deaths are a
mother's love matter to me what it is
God in the lives people choose or the
faith they think they elect matter to me
when we're all elected by the same fate
me and billions of privileged people
like him also call themselves my
brothers couldn't he see couldn't he see
that everyone was privileged there were
only privileged people the others would
all be condemned one day and he would be
condemned - there's a sort of flattening
out a ratio of difference between values
he says you know solemn Otto's dog was
worth just as much as his wife what he's
saying there's a beautiful metaphor to
this dark wind coming out of his future
leveling everything in its path death is
coming for for everybody that's the end
ultimately of absurdity for least in
that human being was extinguished from
the world which will go on without him
which existed before him and which will
not actually miss him
what does anything matter in that case
that's the realization that he has and
it's a realization that you might say
consolidates the way of life that he has
been carrying on so he's refused not
even refused again that's that's too
strong that's too positive of the
negative way of putting it
he has not engaged himself over and over
and over again in opportunities that lay
before him to commit himself either yes
or no he just has he said well I don't
know I'll go along with this and then
I'll go along with this until he comes
to that crux moment of absurdity where
he's confronted with the earth and he
does shoot him once now that he shoots
him for more
and he's not able to ever explain that
none of that ultimately for this
character matters or has value whereas
sense and what does that sort of
experience do for him was interesting he
says as if that blind rage and wash me
clean rid me of hope for the first time
in that night alive with stars and signs
I opened I opened my son's opened myself
to the gentle indifference of the world
finding it so much like myself so much
like a brother really I felt that I had
been happy and was happy again for
everything to be consummated for me to
feel less alone I had only to wish that
there'd be a large crowd of spectators
the day of my execution that they greet
me with cries of hate so what do you
have going on here in the end something
very similar to what's going on at the
end of the mythos if Issus we must
imagine symphysis happy this is a guy
who's not only being imagined happy
Camus is telling us in his own words he
has been happy and he is happy and that
happiness can exist and can take root
out of the very discordant between the
human being the irrational absurd human
being the irrational absurd world they
exist in a kind of fraternal cordial
relationship even when it's a matter of
a world full of hate by others directed
at him for something he can't even
explain or understand
so you know again the question that I
think we have to ask about this is his
caboose taking out a ground here that's
supposed to be the representative
experience the representative character
for his particular brand of
existentialism or is this a sort of
stepping point or perhaps a blind alley
and the other works might show us better
what it is that Camus really has in his
mind in his heart that he wants to
communicate to us but that's an open
question so I leave that for you to
consider and this is normal end